[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo dédiée au nouveau trailer
de doctor strange de et bon sang quel
trailer 1 franchement j'ai beaucoup trop
hâte là ils vont nous proposer une vraie
d'un gris le trailer nous envoie du très
lourd c'est limite si on arrive à suivre
tellement il ya de détail
d'enchaînements de surprises et cetera
donc voilà faut pas que j'aille trop
loin on aura l'occasion de faire de
belles théories voyons déjà ce qui nous
est proposé d'ailleurs je tenais à vous
remercier car on a dépassé les 90 mille
abonnés sur la chaîne c'est vraiment
énorme donc voilà un très grand merci et
puis bah pour celles et ceux qui ne sont
toujours pas abonné bas n'hésitez pas si
les vidéos vous plaît bref allez
commençons enfin commençons je dis ça
mais je ne sais même pas vraiment trop
par où commencer parce qu'il a tellement
d'éléments sortis du contexte du film le
trailer nous montre plein de personnages
qu'on n'a encore jamais vues dans le mc
huées du coup bah on ne connaît pas
encore spécialement lors utilité du coup
il y à vraiment énormément de zones
d'ombré même le scénario en soit on sait
très peu de choses il ya vraiment
énormément de flou et ah oui je préfère
le dire maintenant mais voilà vu que
nous sommes sur une analyse de trailer
n'oubliez pas que marvel m manipuler les
trailer pour nous faire croire certaines
choses donc vous êtes prévenus restons
quand même un petit peu sur nos gardes
allez on va se concentrer sur les
illuminati car le groupe semble bien
centrale par le biais de ce trailer
le groupe illuminati était incliné
depuis un moment via les ligues du film
tout simplement car plusieurs rumeurs
annonçaient certains héros qui font
partie de ce fameux groupe à l'origine
pour ceux qui ne sont pas très familier
avec l'univers marvel les illuminati
c'est une équipe secrète de super-héros
ultra puissant qui prend des décisions
dans l'ombre pour protéger la terre le
plus intéressant avec ce groupe c'est la
diversité puisque afin de couvrir toutes
les communautés et toutes les
problématiques les illuminati sont
composés seulement dayraut bien
spécifiques par exemple nous avons
charles xavier qui symbolisent les x men
et donc les mutants nous avons dr
strange pour tout le côté extra
dimensionnelle màj nous avons à mort
pour atlantis et tout le côté aquatique
tony stark qui est plus globale est un
fervent défenseur de la paix net
monsieur fantastique avec les 4
fantastiques et cetera et cetera vous
avez compris l'idée maintenant vu que
nous sommes dans le mc eu et bien je
pense qu'il ne faut pas trop s'attendre
à la même équipe des comics d'origine
voilà dans le mc hugh on a toujours une
certaine réécriture une adaptation donc
plusieurs entités peuvent faire partie
de ce fameux groupe mais du coup vous
allez me demander qui sera dans le
groupe d'illuminati du mca qui semble
d'ailleurs pas mal tourné autour du
multivers eh bien je vais tenter de
répondre à la question car j'ai
découvert pas mal de choses dans le
trailer tout d'abord docteur strange
fait face à six sièges donc on doit
s'attendre à une équipe de six personnes
au moins le premier a été révélé avec sa
voix et c'était le leak le plus solide
qui existaient charles xavier arrive
dans le mc hugh par le biais des
illuminati et détail intéressant quand
charles xavier s'adresse à dr strange il
est positionné sur la gauche du docteur
et si nous regardons le plan d'avant
nous voyons que sur la gauche du docteur
un siège évident un autre est occupé par
un autre illuminati dont nous allons
parler juste après il reste donc le
siège caché par le corps du docteur
celui appartenant à très forte chance à
celui de charles xavier concernant cet
autre illuminati que nous avons
mentionné il s'agit à très forte chance
pour moi de rides richard's soit
monsieur fantastique effectivement parmi
l'élite les plus solides reed richards
êtes un héros très attendu pour
apparaître dans doctor strange 2 sachant
qu'en plus il est un incontournable du
groupe des illuminati et puis détail
important nous voyons qu'il porte une
sorte d' un signe sur la partie gauche
de sa poitrine
tout comme le costume officiel de
monsieur fantastique si rien n'a bougé
nous devrions avoir john krasinski dans
le rôle puisqu'il est censé devenir le
reid richard's du mc hugh pour continuer
il est sûr à 1000% pour moi que nous
aurons à variant de tony stark dans le
groupe déjà pareil c'est possiblement la
rumeur la plus populaire de dr strange 2
le fait d'avoir à un tony stark joué par
tom cruise mais surtout nous pouvons
remarquer que le groupe d'illuminati est
toujours entourée de bottes dutronc
docteur strange se fait même escortée
par ces derniers et ça pour moi c'est le
détail qui tue puisqu'évidemment hull
tron et la création de tony stark c'est
l'une de ces signatures et encore plus
dans le mc hugh donc pour moi ça nourrit
ville complètement la présence d'un tony
stark dans le groupe du coup cela veut
dire que dans un autre univers tony
stark n'aurait pas foiré la création du
tronc et aurait réussi du premier coup
je trouve ça plutôt marrant bon et
quatrième membre là je vous avoue qu'on
va rentrer dans du détail est
possiblement le coeur du film dans le
trailer nous remarquons qu'il ya
clairement un problème avec doctor
strange pourquoi tout simplement car il
se fait traqué par les illuminati c'est
quelque chose qui revient à plusieurs
reprises par le biais d'un trailer mais
il semblerait qu'il existe un mauvais dr
strange ou plusieurs tout est possible
retournons sur le premier trailer là bas
nous faisons face à un bordeaux qui
clame haut et fort que la menace de
l'univers c'est bel et bien dr strange
sauf que détail hyper intéressant
maintenant que nous avons le second
trailer c'est le moment où strange
affronte bordeaux si nous regardons
attentivement ce passage bordeaux
affronte un strange menotté qui possède
sa tunique bleue mais sans sac à et dans
un lieu très particulier
c'est en fait le qg des illuminati ou
reconnaît le design très épuré des lieux
ainsi que ses fenêtres et strange
possède la même tenue et m noté et
d'ailleurs si nous prenons un temps pour
regarder le plan avec les sièges des
illuminati nous voyons un protagoniste
en train de marcher et bien il s'agirait
de mort de ce dernier possède une
tunique longue et il ya comme une sorte
d'épée sur son dos exactement comme
bordeaux dans le premier trailer et là
je vous avoue que c'est plutôt
intéressant car cela voudrait dire que
bordeaux fait partie des illuminati
alors il est fortement possible que ce
ne soit pas le même bordeaux que celui
de notre univers enfin on n'en sait rien
du tout en fait tout est possible mais
déjà cela veut dire qu'il n'ya pas ou du
moins pas encore de dr strange dans le
groupe des illuminati car si l'on suit
la logique de la diversité dont je vous
ai fait part au début de la vidéo et
bien bordeaux symboliserait le côté
magique soit le sorcier du groupe et en
plus de ça c'est lui qui nous apprend
que strange est la plus grande menace
donc cela justifie sa capture par les
illuminati d'ailleurs autre point
intéressant il semblerait que strange ne
soit pas le seul prisonnier des
illuminati puisque durant un plan très
court nous voyons une america's chavez
enfermé dans une cage de verre à côté
d'une christine palmer un petit peu
paniqué nous voyons d'ailleurs une autre
cage en verre qui doit être possiblement
celle du docteur sans oublier évidemment
le bot hull tron qui vient confirmer que
nous sommes chez les illuminati sachant
que comme dans le premier trailer
strange est accompagné de christine
palmer est america chavez voilà on
comprend qu'ils forment une sorte de
groupe et se sont fait attraper
néanmoins je viens de le dire palmer
semblait paniqué il semble que le qg des
illuminati va se faire attaquer à un
moment ou un autre et c'est à ce moment
que nous arrivons au cinquième membre du
groupe nous savons que woods a fait
équipe avec dr strange dans ce film mais
la majorité du temps nous ne la voyons
pas en compagnie d'amérique à chavez ou
encore palmer c'est comme si il y a les
deux temps un temps où strange est avec
palmer et chavez et un autre où il est
seul avec wendat et d'ailleurs quand il
va voir au rwanda à la campagne avec ses
dires nous comprenons qu'il a déjà vécu
certaines choses avec le multivers alors
qu'à la base il ne connaît rien de ce
concept donc possiblement au rwanda
arrivera un peu plus tard dans le film
mais bon ce n'est pas la question la
base je m'égare un petit peu je disais
que le qg des illuminati va se faire
attaquer et là c'est un point très
intéressant wendat qui n'est justement
jamais avec le groupe de strange palmer
et chavez arrive soudainement dans le qg
des illuminati et affronte ce qui
semblerait être une variante de captain
marvel avant que nous entamions ce
fameux débat entourant captain marvel
luanda affronte cette entité dans le qg
car si nous regardons bien le plan on
retrouve une des statues du qg donc ce
n'est pas anodin de penser que wendat va
possiblement venir délivrer docteur
strange et son groupe bon alors moi
perso je vois une maria rambo en captain
marvel je sais que certains et certaines
voix un suprême iron man mais je ne sais
pas moi personnellement je vois plutôt
une femme en plus elle ressemble
clairement à l'actrice de maria rambo et
surtout c'est une bonne idée de variants
une maria rambo en captain marvel au
lieu de carole dans un autre univers
surtout que c'est le même code visuel et
de couleurs que ce que nous proposait le
film captain marvel donc voilà alors
j'ai également vu que ça parlait d'une
monica rambo mais je vous avoue que je
ne suis pas trop d'accord avec cette
idée puisque déjà elle ne ressemble pas
à monica et en plus monica est
normalement complètement hors de toute
cette histoire puisqu'elle est censée
aller dans l'espace rejoindre nick fry
au rythme et du coup le fait que marié
rambo affrontements n'da dans le qg des
illuminati cela veut dire à très fortes
chances qu'elle fait partie des lieux et
donc par conséquent qu'elle fait partie
des illuminati et en soit c'est pas mal
puisque avec la logique du groupe déjà
captain marvel fait partie des héros les
plus puissants de l'univers et en plus
elle apporte une diversité au groupe
étant spécialisé dans l'espace en tout
cas voilà c'est ma visite on j'ai
peut-être tort j'ai peut-être raison à
vous de me dire ce que vous croyez est
ce que vous pensez enfin sixième membre
du groupe c'est une idée un petit peu
farfelue mais je n'arrive pas à me dire
que ce ne serait pas ça et pour ça il
faut que nous nous dirigions vers le
nouveau poster du film sur ce poster
nous remarquons plein de détails et de
variations de doctor strange ou encore
au rwanda mais il ya un élément qui me
fait tiquer déjà nous avons le symbole
illuminati histoire de bien nous
confirmer leur présence mais surtout
nous avons le bouclier de captain carter
captain carter c'est possiblement la
plus vieille rumeur de doctor strange 2
elle est censée apparaître dedans et on
en avait déjà pas mal parlé à l'époque
en fait captain carter déjà cela
provient de captain britain qui est un
défenseur du multivers donc rien qu'avec
cette origine cela colle parfaitement à
la situation mais en plus de ça nous
savons que doctor strange 2 sera lié à
plusieurs éléments de what if comme la
présence du fameux gargan tos slash
chaumât gauras les zombies a mené via le
trailer et le ti vie spot ou encore
possiblement le evil dr strange mais bon
rien de sûr de ce côté là d'ailleurs
c'est peut être un peu farfelue mais
dans le plan avec les sièges des
illuminati il reste une entité présente
que nous n'avons pas mentionné cette
personne est bien perso je trouve
qu'elle ressemble pas mal à captain
carter cela semble quelqu'un de plutôt
musclé et avec une longue chevelure
captain carter ayant le sérum du
super-soldat bas elle est plutôt musclé
et en plus elle a de longs cheveux donc
voilà je pose salah mais ça ne me paraît
pas idiot donc pour résumer nous aurions
une équipe d'illuminati composé de chars
xavier reid richard's tony stark
bordeaux marié rambo en captain marvel
et enfin captain carter mais bon je peux
avoir tort 1 ce n'est que ma vision en
tout cas le film promet du très lourd on
comprend qu'il ya un gros souci avec dr
strange mais bon tour est hyper flou
pour le moment nous avons d'ailleurs la
présence d'un défendeurs strange
invariants qui fait partie de l'équipe
des défendeurs moi je ne sais pas vous
mais je sens bien qu'à la fin du film
notre docteur strange je souhaiterais
pourquoi pas fonder une équipe pour le
futur actuellement il n'ya plus vraiment
de tim d'avengers tim dyer d'avengers
que strange a côtoyé là avec son second
opus il va côtoyer d'autres groupes
comme bah du coup celui des illuminati
ou bien du coup bas s'il rencontre le
défendeur strange qui fait partie du
groupe des défendeurs et bien du coup il
va faire que de côtoyer des groupes de
super héros et en plus dont les variants
font partie de ces groupes donc voilà
peut-être ça va lui donner l'idée d'en
former également il ya plein de choses
intéressantes concernant ou honda ça
sent la grosse remise en question sur
l'injustice qu'elle subit il est clair
que wendat est le personnage qui
souffrent le plus elle est souvent
pointé du doigt mais voilà la vidéo
commence déjà à être bien longue on fera
une vidéo dédiée à luanda dans les jours
à venir je vous avoue que j'avais prévu
de le faire depuis déjà quelques temps
on va s'arrêter là en vrai il ya encore
plein de choses à dire mais je pense
qu'il faut aussi repenser à tête reposée
histoire de de mieux analyser et mieux
réfléchir donc voilà affaire à suivre
j'espère que ma vidéo vous aura plu on
s'est vraiment beaucoup concentré sur le
groupe des illuminati mail avec ce
trailer on comprend clairement qu'ils
auront une très grande importance dans
le film je souhaitais également dire que
moi perso j'attend clairement un caméo
de magnéto c'est peut-être bête mais
dans les comics magnéto et le père de
luanda et en plus de ça c'est un très
grand manipulateur donc voilà faire
rencontrer rwanda et un magnéto d'un
autre univers sachant quenza pour y
trouver une sorte de lien est une
affection paternelle
j'aime vraiment l'idée mais bon on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler écoutez
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleu un
petit commentaire sur ce que vous avez
pensé du trailer ou si vous avez
remarqué une petite d'un gris parce que
franchement c'est largement possible vu
tout ce qu'il y a et puis n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner pour ne pas louper les
prochaines vidéos voilà 7 et argo rock
et que le lionheart sont avec vous allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]